Micke in in bringing this project around
and kind of getting it off the ground
after some gestation period what what
was your fuel what did you see the film
as well how did you envision it I saw it
like the state estate said you know I
want to be a high energy lots and lots
of music which there's I mean there's a
lot of songs in the movie a lot of
performance songs in the movie so that
you know that carries a look there's
also incredible you know emotional
scenes but there's an incredible amount
of music and performance in it so I saw
it as a higher energy piece with
covering normally when you do one of
these biopic see quite often take just a
slice of the person's life because it's
very hard to encompass a whole whole
life in a biopic it's really hard to do
so one of the normal ways of going about
that is just to take like one year you
know like say we could have said let's
just take Boston you know and and the
the show that he did in Boston when
Martin Luther King died because it's
just taken that but this this was a
script that that encompassed the whole
of his life the childhood the teenage
years the the peak years and into into
him being quite old so that's this was
you know a hard task to accomplish but I
think we managed to do that in this
picture
well it started I met James Brown about
15 or 16 years ago and very you know was
very attracted to James Brown I loved
his music I lived with his music as a
kid I was in a car club a lowrider club
and and everybody that's what that's
what you listen to you listen to James
Brown or little Anthony and Imperials
but just a but I loved it and I I was I
said to him can I make a movie about
your life and said he'd think about it
that gestation period is about three
years and eventually he just said yes he
would do it and I spoke to relatives and
people and and then I worked on us then
I bought the rights I renewed the rights
I hired writers I hired a director but
it would start and then stop because was
a very hard movies are very hard to
create they're sort of a their
foundational component
and make those right and I couldn't
really assemble it correctly I never
really had the right actor now we did or
do like an eye and we never really had
the right director that really
understood it and now we do and but but
just to just kind of finish this story
so had this had the rights ten years
lost the rights when James Brown died a
year later Mick and I had contact with
each other and he generously you know we
his conversation and sort of generously
agreed that we would do it together and
he'd read the script like the script but
also of course wanted changes and then
we just created a system Mick is very
systematic and which is a good thing and
we created a system about producing the
movie together we got some energy and
some momentum going on on the project
and it's very quickly for this kind of
movie and for doing it through a through
a studio very quickly became a reality
and before we knew we were we were
actually shooting the picture and I
think tape was the person that really
helped us as soon as we got tight
onboard tape abort an incredible energy
and forward momentum to the to the whole
process
and we his enthusiasm and energy kept it
moving on and casting it really well
really quickly surrounding the main
character with with one four other cast
and so that really kept the movie moving
and you know in a short space of time we
got to the screen it was it was really
just a regimen every day just dance
rehearsal five days a week
vocal rehearsals two or three times a
week and I'm reading and watching
footage I did I never could let a day
pass because we had such a limited
amount of time doing it and I have to
credit that work ethic credit 42 went
for that because it was a similar
process if it had not been for going
through that there was no way I could
even wrap my head around this process so
that's pretty much what it was just just
diving in every day he was James Brown
from soon as your feet hit the floor
this man had two months he was not a
trained dancer he had two months to
prepare for what you saw this is amazing
she was one of the first people in the
very formative years of his life to give
him that stability and that's very
necessary in order for a child to
blossom and I think that aunt honey gave
him by giving him that stability tough
love
mind you and the responsibility that he
had to contribute to the household at
like five or six that he he learned very
early on what worked ethic was and we
saw that played out and his becoming the
hardest-working man in show business
business but at the same time he you
know there with darkness there is light
and with light there is darkness so we
got to see that duality played out and
you know sometimes your devices do tend
to catch up with you and that was great
about James Brown he was a very complex
man so I think Chadwick did an amazing
job bringing that essence and and
everything visceral about James Brown to
life what I knew of James Brown I mean I
loved his music we were at James Brown
family and I was not aware of all of the
adversity in in his childhood
so until we were getting ready to do
this film so I was really touched by the
things I don't know that I would have
had the resolve as a five-year-old to be
out in the woods for stretches of time
alone and there there's a something very
substantive about who he was at that
early age that informed me of who he
became because we knew how the story
ended
it didn't know very much about how it
began and maybe some of the middle so I
was really really taken back by that and
it was something that struck me dan I've
got to talk to you about Ben Bart but
first I have to say of course that you
met and worked with James Brown when he
played the Reverend clay Alice in the
Blues Brothers which people of my
generation know very well and also again
in blues go to 2000 you were singing
backup to please please please in 1998
what was it like to work with him on
those two bills well he agreed to do
actually three films of Doctor Detroit
the most important film of my life
because I met my wife Donna on that film
right there and there she is and she
know James and James was very fond of
Donna also he agreed to open five House
of Blues nightclubs so I got to hire him
to do five of his amazing shows with his
band the soul generals and and his two
timpani players and his dancing girls
and the Sweet Inspirations his
incredible vocal show you've got the
mole in there iiiiii no no Danny ray RJ
I mean you know the Reverend this and
that man that hung around with him and
so uh so you know uh what happened here
is is that we found a talent that that
could wrap his head and his and his
abilities are around all of the elements
of James and you know Chadwick just I
guess he started with the voice the
hoarseness the gravelly the the cadence
all of that he brought that kind of
paranoia that James had about people
trying to screw him to the character he
brought that fear that James could
instill in other people if they weren't
doing what he wanted all of that and
then of course the sparkle dazzle
dynamite and lightning of the musical
performances so I saw James I danced on
stage with him maybe a dozen times I
emceed his coming out of prison show at
The Wiltern theater III you know I knew
him very well and and I must say that
what we have here is not in a not an
impression or duplication or replication
we have a really an actor just doing
what actors do and that is to be
the B the B the part they're supposed to
be playing there's an embarrassment of
riches and it's also a curse when you're
trying to tell this man story I mean all
the people he touched all the people he
met the ways he continually reinvented
himself
it's where do you start and I wish we
could have a seven-hour movie I would if
people would watch them I tried I tried
did he go over very well but but with
our story we wanted to get the
information out there without a lot of
the conventional ways that you would do
it in a biopic and and the first thing
we decided was that if anybody was going
to rise from the dead and get involved
in his own story it would be mr. Brown
and who better to brag and be truthful
with us than him telling his own story
then that led into well I thought to
myself how can I get all of his the
titles he had and I had the idea of it
being kind of a chapter heading and it
just went from there and with our movie
we can break all the rules and do what
we want Nelson I always thought that
Bobby Byrd like a lot of artists who are
always behind a great man or a great
artist a great woman was sort of the the
force that kept him in check
it seems to me after watching the movie
and it would be interested in hearing
what your research found he thought that
James Brown was a genius
and he knew that James Brown was the
front man and he was going to learn from
him and he's going to be his side man he
was it used the anchor I mean there was
a lot of people in and out of James
Ronald's life but Bobby was consistent
he was there he didn't move
except when they had to part well he's
just an amazing musician I just think
he's his music crosses countries and
boundaries I loved his music I didn't
actually know
his life until we started working on
this project make it being approached to
do a documentary about James Brown and
said well let's do a film so we started
researching and that was it was
thrilling actually once you start
digging in and finding out about him and
it's a joy to work on this so I think
that there's no reason for it to be
American or English or any other country
it's just an incredible story my
publicist has been bugging me for the
last week about this playlist' that I
had to do for beach music which we did
like the 25 they'll go download this
because it's kind of ratchet the 25
greatest hip hop songs the sample James
Brown music so you hearing this like all
of all of these you know just classics
like you hear those samples and the
songs and he I wonder like that would be
hip hop but it wouldn't be nearly the
same thing without you know the funky
drummer is like a break beat this is
used in like so many songs that
thousands of songs that have have been
dead of use James Brown samples and not
just hip hop R&B soul jazz house it's so
much so much music that it would make
your head spin and it some people are
probably sampling and trying to hide it
in ways the way you can't tell that
they're doing it I might have found some
song about this but but it's it's vast
in terms of that it's vast in terms of
the music that we still listen to and
it's vast in terms of you know the
artists that that are emulating and have
been inspired by him that that we listen
to now Bruno Mars Janelle Monae Michael
Jackson Prince uh sure
neo Justin Timberlake Pharrell like it's
Kanye West like it's so many different
artists that
you know pay homage to him every day